considerable uncertainty about the
economic outlook remains the latest
readings on the labor market and the
week pace of investment illustrate one
downside risk the domestic demand might
falter in addition although I'm
optimistic about the longer run
prospects for the US economy we cannot
rule out the path of possibility
expressed by some prominent economists
that the slow productivity growth seen
in recent years will continue into the
future
vulnerabilities in the global economy
also remain
although concerns about slowing growth
in China and falling commodity prices
appear to have eased from earlier this
year China continues to face
considerable challenges as it rebalances
its economy toward domestic demand and
consumption and away from export led
growth more generally in the current
environment of sluggish growth low
inflation and already very accommodative
monetary policy in many advanced
economies investor perceptions of an
appetite for risk can change abruptly
one development that could shift
investor sentiment is the upcoming
referendum in the United Kingdom a UK
vote to exit the European Union could
have significant economic repercussions
for all of these reasons the committee
is closely monitoring global economic
and financial developments and their
implications for domestic economic
activity labor markets and inflation